imaginons qu'un ordinateur souhaite un
bel objet
un objet qu'on regarde qu'on veut avant
chez soi imaginons au lieu de le mettre
en de bonnes mains
si on le mettait entre toutes les mains
ce serait le plus grand séisme dans le
monde puisse dieu cours de paix le
premier je te supplie de modérer les
attentes
est-ce que j'étais déjà déçu à chaque
occasion alors je me lance
les actions apple val 441 millions de
dollars pendant que ta fille et sa mère
vit des allocs
elle n'est pas à ma fille elle te
ressemble tu dois t'en rendre compte on
saura bien assez tôt cité léonard de
vinci ou si tu te prends juste pour lui
tu es la seule personne qui voit le
monde comme
personne ne voit le monde comme toi le
monde entier attend le mac
qu'est ce que les gens vont faire ils
vont faire ça tu donne des ordres
contradictoires
tu est ingérable tu pourrit la vie des
gens le conseil estime que cette
entreprise n'a plus besoin de toi
du fond de mon garage j'ai inventé
accueillir les artistes ouvrent la voie
et moutons vote à main levée le meilleur
de toi même c'est pas ce que tu crées
être un père ça devrait plutôt être ça
le meilleur de toi même je suis seul ici
à savoir que ce type là est un
personnage que tu t'es inventé
tu as un plan d'action le plan d'action
te sera révélé quand tu sera prête
cofondateur revient chez apple
les deux points culminants du 20e siècle
la victoire des alliés et âmes
merci
jobs